[Music]
if 2017 was the year where the eSports
industry began to dream about how great
franchising might be then 2018 was a
year where that dream became a reality
this is a very big shift I'm excited
about it because these boats is very
young it is in its development it is
something that at the scale we're seeing
is still unprecedented so that means we
can define it would you take control of
our own future
and well it's definitely too early to
say whether the teams that have invested
in the na LCS and the over our league
will be making a return on their
investment we can definitely see how
much eSports is benefited from
franchising in 2018
[Music]
let's start with League of Legends where
the battle to end relegation was fought
and won prior to 2018 the constant
threat of relegation in regions other
than China which franchise in summer
2017 meant that teams weren't
necessarily playing to win as much as
you're playing not to lose their spawn
the league altogether the issue is that
teams that were relegated were
essentially deemed irrelevant as soon as
you drop below that right align your
sponsors would pull out your roster
would dissolve and the organization
would be faced with the possibility of
simply cutting its losses and getting
out of league we've seen how some teams
were once ruling the world Moscow 5 that
became gambit and then faded into
obscurity Alliance have an EU LCS
champion under the belt and they haven't
played competitive league in years what
franchising will do for the na LCS and
presumably will do for the LEC and any
other region that chooses to franchise
like the ljl is create a sense of
stability not only did it earn a riot
over a hundred million dollars and buy
in fees and na it also gave players and
teams some much-needed financial
security it seems like it's the way to
go right now to kind of upgrade sort of
again the the stability of the league in
general I think it makes eSports
tournaments a lot more appealing to
sponsors both on the league level in the
team level and again you want you want
commitment from people right and when
you get the teams involved in the league
to that degree you know that brings I
think a level of commitment to making
sure the league goes well and sticks
around for a long time that maybe didn't
exist to that degree in the past and to
understand how franchising can help the
competitive side of the game one needs
look no further than cloud 9 and their
incredible run through the back half of
the year
after fizzling out near the end of the
2018 spring split cloud line started the
summer split by making some
controversial roster myths going forward
playing with the economy team and your
if your goal is to be on the cloud NLCS
team you would prove it by being
professional working hard working hard
for teammates to cloud9 benched sneaky
jensen and smoothie three tried and
tested superstars four academy players
at golden glow' keith and nasal the main
goal here is to make sure that we have
players are extremely passionate about
playing and winning this change has had
a dramatic improvement in the players
desire to get better and push themselves
to a higher level and so you're going to
see a team that has a new sense of fire
and passion to do well on stage it was a
big risk but Conine could take it in
part because they knew they wouldn't
face relegation if it didn't pan out
without increased stability it allows me
to invest more and developing new talent
really digging into local talent and
then a I can really invest in that try
to find those future stars and you know
get them an Academy house get them
really good coaching and management make
sure that we're paying these guys a good
salary for the amount of work that
they're putting into it the thing is it
did a pan out despite a rough start to
the split cloud9 brought back a
revitalized and repentant sneaky and
Jensen and he made it all the way to the
playoffs grand finals and then worlds
and at world
cloud9 became the first na team to make
it the top four since season one
gonna clean up the map and the last
vestige of Korea has been destroyed
cloud9 will make it to the semi-finals a
3-0 sweep the first time in seven years
cloud nine in the top cloud nines run
was nothing short of historic and
chances are it wouldn't have happened
without franchising
[Music]
the thing that makes overwatch and it's
league so unique is that it was designed
with franchising in mind overwatch is
the first time at least anyone has
successfully I would say taking a game
that just had no real eSports base I get
immediate but like this was a game that
was my oh and was like this will be an
eSports game people will play this for
eSports and there will be a league I
think it's one of those things that's
gonna take more time to really you know
judge obviously we're only one year in
but I think initially it's looking
pretty good I think it's brought a lot
of stability to the players that are
involved in the league in that you know
now these guys are earning a little
weight and when it comes down to it we
want this industry to be a place where
everybody from the top to bottom can
make a little wage doing the same
whether it's players casters people
wearing working in the production
statisticians you know I mean we want
everybody to be able to make eSports
their job right because that's when we
know we've really created a new industry
we're not just having a bunch of you
know what off tournaments and things
like that you look at the overwatch
league right now and every match that
they've played has been in LA and to my
knowledge will be through probably the
rest of the year which we do have teams
that have geographic affiliations but
not necessarily physical footprints and
from a logistical standpoint that's kind
of the best of both worlds because you
don't have to pay for travel for our
teams to play in all these different
locations but you can start to start and
test the water of fan affinity in those
regions you can start to see what fandom
can develop just from affiliation with
with an eSports brand in 2017 many
investors felt that what ESPN is jacob
wolf reported to me a 20 million dollar
buy-in a feat of the over actually with
far too steep for a league that didn't
even exist yet flash forward to 2018 and
wolf is now reporting that the eight new
overwatch league teams this year paid
between thirty and sixty million dollars
a piece there is no doubt in the first
season the overall it was a success for
Blizzard the company has netted a
hundred and fifty million dollars in
broadcast deals of sponsorship rights
and reportedly has pulled in nearly half
a billion dollars in buy-in fees alone
the big question is whether teams in the
overwatch league will be able to earn a
return on their
according to blizzard the only way
that's going to happen is through
geolocation or affiliating each team
with a different city in the world the
entirety of the overwatch Elise
continued growth depends on whether or
not these owners who spent tens of
millions of dollars on their teams can
make a return on their investment
through advertising merchandising
sponsorship and ticket sales Blizzard
have said that teams will eventually
play home-and-away games in stadiums all
over the world operated by the teams
themselves this is an enormous
undertaking and Blizzard is allegedly
aiming to make it happen by 2020 this
has never been done before and while
overwatch ly your viewership is good
those numbers don't tell the whole story
the first season of the overall Chile
could put up some surprisingly
impressive numbers when the San
Francisco Shock battled against the Los
Angeles valiant in the first match of
stage 1 the English language twitch
broadcast attracted nearly 400,000
concurrent viewers and even after the
league's novelty began to wear off the
stream still averaged just shy of 9
million hours watched a month the
problem is that going forward views
aren't going to be enough to justify
blizzards all-in stance on geolocation
racking of twitch views is fantastic but
teams don't need to operate their own
stadiums to make that happen but if
franchises are actually able to
capitalize on geolocation and the games
player base continues to grow then the
overwatch league could genuinely be
something groundbreaking looking forward
with the regionalization thing we know
what's gonna happen just how exactly
it's going to happen remains to be seen
it's gonna be pretty fun and exciting
when it does more teams in the league
next years have already been announced a
lot more great players a lot play a lot
of players that probably should have had
a chance last year to be involved are
getting that chance now this year
because of all those expansion teams so
a pretty exciting time to be like
ultimately if franchises do lead to
teams eventually building actual arenas
to play overwatch in it could assure in
a new era for competitive gaming one
that closely resembles traditional
sports
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button